hello everybody my name is Marta Marta
welcome to the demonic Wales of Steve's
office I'm actually just gonna start
there because holy hell that was
extremely loud remember he's all seem
like familiar okay alright then Steve is
really tall or way man just know you oh
good
but why is it so dark around here good
thing I have a little flashlight
attached to my keys okay yeah it's the
clicky dude yet okay so this is another
indie horror game that's made on the
same engine as the old slenderman's
shadow maps just e to use doors
Bartowski all right there it is and I
once again have the volume turned up way
super-high what was Sparrow melt huh
what the hell was that named Sparrow
melih he must be down there ah
down where whoo look physics physics
okay
well I'm looking for the weirdo names
Sparrow melih
in this dark and dank office that sound
sounds them what oh okay okay that one
is locked and there's a downstairs is
this worse spit one why would I need to
crouch what are you trying to tell me
game why do I need a crowd where's he
I'll just get a Crouch preemptively cuz
I know you're gonna throw something at
me I know there's enemies up I know
there's gonna be some out there hello
hello
oh wait a minute no no there we go I
gotta turn the light off too wait no
what now where's my my light
excuse me you may not have a light
anymore why not I seriously don't have a
light anymore what happened did I bug
out oh no oh no oh no oh I got a bad
feelin about
so what happened I picked up a doodad it
is good I turned me this dumb you stay
something you say something I must have
fudge oh oh I got it
oh I put it away oh okay alright now
that I got it back
that actually concerned me I thought I
drove there was a door here I never even
noticed hello haha loading screen of
doom now this is broken into three parts
apparently
and I depending on the length of each
part of ah hi how's it going
you look good you feel good feel the
energy your face
stop with that don't need for that shut
up
I don't want any goddamn it god damn it
yeah he's style me fire get out of here
Jesus what is going on in this horrid
hell oh look you're feeding blood oh oh
oh
close a damn door Oh can we settle down
for two seconds it got a little extreme
yeah I got a key what does that mean we
kind of demented Oh Oh like a boss of
course kind of demented office is this
oh my god close it I can't oh good a
long one bully how without startling and
Lao whoa what excuse me pardon me
what can you say that again you think
okay
and it's quite hmm okay just open the
damn door shut up I don't need it what
am I not mad you're into the hands
shut up for two seconds god damn it he's
oh okay I'm gonna just stand here not
move not gonna move okay are we done
are you done shut up shut up shut up
don't hang back here
look care about your soul tree would
shut up no no no oh god aah aah aah
Oh dead body dog back off of me boy am i
oh yeah I'm out here I'm out here
[ __ ] jump Afghan oh there's blood on
my screen lovely
that was part one I guess that's the end
of it I don't even know how long I've
been doing it I'm gonna turn that down
thank you okay huge baby can you back up
for a little bit there okay I don't know
how long I've been recording um cuz this
is full screen and usually I can see a
timer going on but I can't right now but
uh I'm just gonna add it here go to the
next one later go anyway thank you all
so much for watching click the entities
for videos that I've done as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
not a rock
yeah
ah bomb hurt
the huggers are
Oh God
backlash to it
the elephant is big I got a gun davon
don't make me drop everything